première émission des jeux de 20h nous
jouons avec bordeaux bonsoir bordeaux
bonsoir jean pierre et bien bonsoir
jackson laisse beaucoup de monde en
effet dans notre studio de notre station
régionale bordeaux d'ailleurs ils vont
faire un petit peu de bruit pour rien
qu'on va qui sont tous là voilà fils ont
déjà été sélectionnés ils sont prêts à
jouer de nombreux nombreux juges sont en
pleine forme et nous avons dans lol par
contre d'autres candidats qui attendent
d'être sélectionné en compagnie de
daniel d'obélix en gohelle
enfin dominique bonsoir jacques ça va
très bien d'ailleurs vous allez entendre
la voix de but bordelais tout va bien
dominique quand tout va bien nous sommes
prêts également dans le studio ce soir
nos candidats vont jouer avec micheline
dax bouffard micheline avec jan valtin
habitudes des gens trop dit lui même la
nounou et robert rocca et laure là
maintenant un grand moment de cette
émission je vous demande un peu de
silence un peu de recueillement je vous
présente maître capello si si si si
c'est lui-même capello arbitre du beau
langage trésorier et juge unique de
cette édition
maître capello candidats de bordeaux
maître capello a sélectionné pour vous
une phrase d'un auteur connu cette
phrase vous allez devoir la reconstituer
en fin d'émission mais pour avoir le
droit de la reconstituer vous allez
subir quelques épreuves préliminaires
cette phrase nous la regardons ensemble
elle vaut mille francs pour l'instant
elle comporte 8 mo le lait est et est
bien entendu cinq autres mots et chaque
candidat qui trouvera un mot de cette
phrase est bien fera augmenter la valeur
de cette phrase de 1000 francs donc pour
l'instant elle vaut mille francs nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure et nous
espérons que les candidats vont faire
grossir la valeur de cette phrase et on
peut empocher le contenu du petit cochon
rose de jacques capelovici qui est d'ici
si vous avez des idées mais chelem
jean-robert surtout ne vous gênez pas
tout à l'euro fait de nouveau les deux
morts
voilà et bien pour l'instant commençons
notre sélection avec un premier jeu
dominique oui voilà la première
candidate est en place à ce que je vois
oui c'était joli florence bâton lui ai
demandé son prénom
non pardon florès un merci mme joly dans
le 7 10 mai je m'excuse et j'avais
compris fleurs fera très bien vos
soirées et bien florence vous avez lu ce
matin dans le journal sud ouest le mot
calumet au pluriel comme celui qui est
affichée là bien entendu et nous avons
donc eu tout le temps de vous prépare
maintenant micheline dax va tenter de
vous faire deviner un mot issu des
lettres de calumet en vous proposant une
définition de son cru sommes bien
d'accord
oui bien alors attention nous jouons
pour deux minutes top chrono
michelin s'est alors florence vais tout
de suite commencer par un mot difficile
que je suis très déçu je vais prendre un
missile être carrément ça vous gêne page
1 non pas du tout va bien alors un mot
de six lettres et je vous dis ceux de
charlie chaplin ont fait de l'or
triompher de leurs une autre définition
alors je vous dis dangereux sur la route
laurence dangereux sur la route
combien de lettres s'y laissera 6
également une troisième définition alors
toujours au pluriel casse toujours quand
on est pressé
grâce au toujours comme on est passé à
leur intention
1 2 3 florent je suis désolé vous n'êtes
pas sélectionné mais vous gagnez tout de
même deux places de cinéma gratuites
dont un cinéma de votre choix à bardos à
nouveau solide à s'il vous plaît qu'elle
allait à vau s'il vous plaît des lacets
des lacets bien non
un autre candidat est en place oui bien
sûr madame votre nom marc keller alors
un mot de trois lettres madame son
histoire a défrayé la chronique
son histoire a défrayé la chronique
une autre définition micheline la
réponse coule de source madame nac nac
non non non sauf le temps eu notre lot
willow oui madame vous êtes sélectionné
bravo vous avez envie de retrouver jean
pierre et vous avez d'ores et déjà gagné
53 bonsoir réveiller une autre
définition pour essayer de salom un mot
de trois lettres il peut être gros ou
fin notre définition on ne souffle pas
peut-être pas alors une autre 2010 aux
pêcheries l'esprit n'en manque pas top
c'est terminé et bien je suis désolé
jeune homme nous avons terminé le temps
qu'ils étaient imparties pétition comme
le jeu vous allez me donner le bon bien
sûr je les idées des lumières c'est le
sel c'est le sel bien entendu eh bien m
nous allons sélectionner je crois en une
seule personne qui tout à l'heure en fin
d'émission participera à la fin à la
phrase de maître capello
merci micheline vous avez parfaitement
jouer je vous félicite c'est tout alors
à près de dominique que sandra elle
passons maintenant à note